in this video we'll talk about
eosinophil and its role in immunity yes
no fill plays a vital role in terms of
immunity against parasites
it was first discovered and described by
paul elrich in
1879 and he noticed the unusual capacity
of this cell to be stained with
acetophilic dyes
they play vital role
against parasites and they are involved
in modulating allergic response
eosinophils
constitute one percent of the
circulating leukocytes whereas the
majority are the neutrophils which are
more than 50 percent of that time
but eosinophils are involved in allergic
responses and other infections
relatively few mature eosinophils are
found in the peripheral blood
and generally they are found in specific
locations in the gut and other locations
where they maintained the homeostasis
let's talk about the development of the
eosinophil
eosinophil is formed from the
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell
which give rise to myeloid progenitor
and from the myeloid progenitor
eosinophils are generated
once generated they are secreted into
the bloodstream but inside the
bloodstream they only stay for about 18
hours
they move to tissues like thymus
or the gi tract and they play vital role
in these particular locations
so let's talk about some cellular
features of eosinophil
so first of all let's talk about the
microscopic features so in
hematoxylin yes eosin stain we can see
these eosinophil to be stained with uh
this kind of pink stain you can see
characteristic bilobe nucleus and a lot
of cytoplasmic granules if we look at
the ultrastructure of the eosinophil we
can also appreciate the bilob nucleus
and the electron dense cytoplasmic
granules question is what is there
inside these hydro cytoplasmic granules
what is the content of these granules in
a moment we would get to know that so
let's talk about the molecular features
so first of all let's talk about these
granule contents because granules
constitute a majority of the cytoplasmic
content in eosinophil so there are many
proteins such as major basic protein mbp
one and two eosinophil cationic protein
ecp
eosinophil peroxidase epx and eosinophil
derived neurotoxin edn so these are the
four major components of the cytotox the
cytoplasmic granules other than that
there is cytokine there is other clc
gal10 protein
and in response to many stimuli these
contents are actually released but what
we have to understand these four major
proteins are really important in terms
of nutri
eosinophils function
in subsequent
slides we would understand why they are
important
let's talk about the surface receptors a
little bit but before that let me tell
you other than these
cytotoxic granules there are
proteins such as cytokines various
interleukins are secreted by these
eosinophils
there are growth factors which are
secreted by eosinophils chemokines and
enzymes are also present in these
eosinophils in terms of the surface
molecule we can see there are different
categories of surface receptors
such as cytokine receptors
such as pattern recognition receptors
various tlr's and prrs are there fc
receptor is also there adhesion
receptors such as integrin receptors are
present on the surface there are
chemokine receptors and receptors for
lipid mediators like leukotrienes
prostaglandins etc
now there are also primary granules and
lipid bodies
let's talk about the immune function of
eosinophil
eusenophil as mentioned before plays
vital role in terms of destruction of
parasites
they also play allergic response i mean
they also play vital role in modulating
the overall allergic response along with
mast cells and
other responses
so all the eosinophil derived proteins
are involved in various kind of immune
response again various kinds of
pathogens
such as if we think about antihelment
response antibacterial response
antiviral and immune modulatory response
we would see that epx
ecp and mbp these three proteins which
are the major constituents of the
cytoplasmic granules
they are involved in antihelmint or
antiparasite response
now for antibacterial response ecp and
mbp are responsible for antiviral
response ecp and edn are
responsible similarly there are many
components which can modulate immune
cells and also there are components
which can activate epithelial cells and
change their homeostasis
so eustenophil level goes down in
various situations such as cushing
syndrome
usage of corticosteroids
and in bacteremia
and eosinophil levels goes up in
situations like asthma allergy parasitic
infection etc
so let's try to understand the role of
eosinophil in disease or eustonophilia
or increasing eosinophil number in
context of disease
so the normal number is 0 to 500 beyond
that it is yosinophilia and beyond 1500
cells per microliter is basically hyper
eosinophilia
so in allergic rhinitis eosinophilic
esophagitis food allergy we can see
there is a eustenophilia-like situation
that means the number goes beyond 500.
same condition goes for asthma atopic
dermatitis bulas etc
but in case of nasal polyposis
eosinophil gastritis in these cases the
eosinophilia is pretty severe and almost
it reaches the hypereosinophilia stage
and this is true for chronic helminth
infection as well
in case of several cancers such as
eosinophil leukemias we can see
hypereosunophilia like situation
now eustenophil has a huge role in terms
of immune modulation because eosinophils
can interact with various immune cells
such as macrophages neutrophil dendritic
cells b cells mast cells and th2 cells
and eosinophil derived factors such as
mbp can modulate neutrophil and activate
neutrophil to secrete several other
stuff
also it can modulate dendritic cell and
lead to dendritic cell
activation so that is why eosinophil
derived factors are really important in
context of overall immune modulation so
this is a
function that is beyond fighting the
parasites or getting involved in allergy
so it has a bigger implication in terms
of biology
so in summary we learned
these eosinophils are usual usually
linked with allergic responses such as
asthma or any kind of atopic dermatitis
allergy
they contain acetophelic granules which
are filled up of specific proteins we
looked at the names their functions etc
so eosinophil level changes in disease
they could go up or they could go low in
specific diseases we looked at them and
eosinophils interaction with immune
system brings out the bigger
implications and biology of the
eosinophils function
so you can get many flash cards and
notes in my facebook page so all the
links are provided in the description
also follow me on instagram you can get
these kind of notes and flash cards in
instagram as well you can support my
channel using a patreon paypal
or you can click on the super thanks
option by clicking on the super thanks
option you can pay via net banking paytm
paypal or upi
your small contribution means a lot for
me it would help me to bring out more
quality content for free education
you can get get connected with us using
social media all the social media links
are provided in the description see you
in the next video